hello everyone karen morgan with film
courage the radio show we're here with
alex munoz filmmaker and founder of fyi
filmed by youth inside the folder right
here and so you go into some of the
youth correctional facilities and you
work with the incarcerated population
you make films
and uh we just spent about 50 minutes
talking with you on air and one question
we didn't get to was
why is this population so fascinated by
filmmaking why is this medium
therapeutic for them
well i think they like storytelling
and i also feel
i get the sense that they feel
left out of mainstream media they feel
excluded
so when i show them cameras and tripods
and the tools to tell stories they
get very very excited and
what's interesting about making the
films of this population is they
begin to take ownership of the medium
and they create their own vernacular for
instance instead of mos
they call it nfs which is a known
sound you can bleep that out and if we
do a company move they don't refer to it
as a company move they say okay we're in
trans and trans refers to when a
ward is being transported from one
facility to another or from
a correctional facility to a court
and instead of saying quite on the set
they'll say quiet the barrio
or quiet
be quiet in the ghetto
and
they just end up taking ownership of the
of the medium and they claim it claiming
is their own
i'm curious too do you have any
questions for our audience we
often do a filmmaker question of the day
at the end of the show do you have a
question to pose to our audience and
we'll put it on our facebook page
oh to the question relate to the work i
do with incarcerated youth or filmmaking
oh mostly filmmaking i think filmmaking
yeah
okay
okay my question would be
what can we do
to
nurture
and project
and cultivate the natural gifts and
talents
of young filmmakers from underprivileged
communities to get them to tell their
stories in a powerful way
and the challenge to that is a lot of
youth from
low-income areas are very
they're they're put off by the
pronounced artifice of hollywood films
and they want fair and equitable and
authentic representation so how do we
empower them
to tell their stories
so that we broaden the forum for a
perspective
and what other what other opportunities
can we provide the youth because
fyi is certainly a valid program and
high impact but also there's things like
theater
and poetry and spoken word so
my question might be more of a challenge
which is what can we do to
help more young people from these
disadvantaged communities to find a
voice and to tell their story so that
they feel like they occupy a safe place
on earth
you